oh hello welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig very exciting to have
bachelor
and bachelor in paradise alum kendall
long
on the podcast today we talk about the
whole experience
of her going from being a set dresser
in the art department here in los
angeles to deciding on a whim
to apply for the bachelor to getting
into a very public relationship and
bachelor on paradise
we also talk about her love of taxidermy
and the misconceptions around it
and of course we talk about her brand
new
book just curious a notebook of
questions which
can help anyone out there if you're
looking to get to know anyone
a little bit better this book has all of
the questions that you didn't even know
that maybe you should be asking so
please enjoy this episode of not too
deep with kendall long
kendall thank you so much for being here
i'm so excited to talk to you
um first congratulations i saw a tail
going by
the screen that's pistachio pistachio is
my little uh
weenie dog so i've seen the gram
and pistachio is a great grammar very
very cute
he's very photogenic um so so yes he's
always uh he's over there he's a little
buddy
how did pistachio come into your life um
i rescued him
in january from an organization called
bunny's buddies that wrestled with
korea cool so um he took a 16 hour
flight
and uh yeah i know he's an american
citizen wow
very cool and also at the right time
before the pandemic before quarantine
really i didn't even plan it i was uh i
was like surprised it actually worked so
perfectly
that's awesome um okay so kendall i have
a lot to talk to you about
uh let's start before bachelor let's
start before
all of this began because we've had a
couple people from the
the franchise on the podcast i'm always
fascinated about how
you ended up auditioning or talking to
someone that got you into the show so
what was life like
before the bachelor um life before the
bachelor i was in the art department of
film and television so i was behind the
camera
i was doing creative directing set
dressing and
um so yeah i literally was on set
all the time and so by the time bachelor
um it was so interesting to like me in
front of the camera it almost felt
like i was just working and i was like
yeah
so okay that's interesting to me so you
worked in set dressing so
uh one of the tropes of the bachelor is
you know an abundance of candles and
rose petals and flowers
when you were on the show did you ever
take note did you ever move things
around did you ever try to give notes on
the set
totally did i totally did yeah so
it was so funny because i um
when people would mess the food or some
of the props i would find myself putting
them back and fixing them
just for continuity sake yeah yeah so
hilarious becca martinez on one of our
dates um and there was this really cute
charcuterie plate
um out sitting out there and she turned
all the crackers
and almonds into like this weird hand
thing and i
came back and i was like you're not
supposed to do that like it's just
a weird hand so i mean i definitely
would like my little like type a fixing
personality is definitely place there
yeah that's great and they're like she's
a mole
she works on the crew she must she's
infiltrating
exactly you can't help but feel that
when you're on there you're like who's
the plan
and you realize everyone's just normal
and uh you know
yeah okay so did you watch the show so
you're you're working in the
entertainment industry
how do you are you watching this show
did you
did you see like an open call did
someone reach out to you
so i definitely saw the show before um i
used to watch it with my mom and sister
all the time
and um i actually hadn't watched it in a
while because i was in college and i um
i didn't have a tv um students don't and
so
when i was actually came back to house
at my parents place when they were out
of town
and um we were watching bachelorette
nostalgically we're watching rachel
lindsay's season
oh yeah yeah yeah and so then
um it comes up the whole casting call
and my sister will definitely do it i
was like oh i would never do that i feel
like we all kind of like have like this
pride
thing like oh i would never do that sure
and then i had a couple glasses of wine
and i was like like filling out the
questionnaire
and um i think i said i'm a ukulele
playing
taxidermy collecting twin and they're
like there's our weirdo
wow yeah
that's so fascinating because i
do have a like skepticism about those
title screens that come up that says
like if you're interested
in finding love i'm like this has to be
[ __ ] there's no way that this is
just how you do it you just blindly send
in something but you did
yeah that's what i did i sent it in and
it was pretty easy from there they just
i just did a bunch of interviews and met
all the producers and i really liked all
of them
and um it just seemed like a really fun
experience and i was like why not
did you have to submit uh an audition
tape
no i actually lived really close to the
office so
i just it's like literally 10 drop 10
minute drive
and yeah it was so convenient i already
lived in l.a
so perfect so i'm sure you checked a lot
of boxes for the show in general
yeah this girl is right there it's easy
so um
so yeah i know there's a lot of people
that do have videos and there's like
open casting calls and stuff right
interesting and so the sister you're
talking about is your twin sister
yeah my twin sister kylie now because
you guys are twins and because you know
the resemblance is there and you're
going on a national television show
did she have any reservations about how
that would affect
her world um not really she's very
supportive the whole time
i think like as a twin you feel like oh
we're so different no one's ever going
to see us as the same person
right i'm sorry my dog is whining
oh it's okay mistake he's just like he's
like giving me attention mom
oh i know that's literally my door's
shut and my dog if i opened it you'd
just see her face staring like why is
the door shut i don't know
um but yeah so my sister uh she was one
that recommended i should go on
so um she was supported the entire time
and it was funny because
sometimes people would like oh are you
kendall it's like oh no i'm her twin
sister
so that was definitely part of it but
she was very [ __ ] with it
yeah now when you so you agree to do
this you sign up
is there how long before you like made
the official yes
before you actually go to set and are
kind of like whisked away and
sequestered
it's pretty quick i mean um so they
don't give you a chance to
overthink it no i mean i definitely did
a lot of that
um i think you do the first interview
and there's like a
a bunch of interviews so um they're kind
of just narrowing it down i'm sure
there's just
so many people who want to be on the
show so they have to
really kind of figure out who's the best
who what's the best group for the
bachelor bachelorette
um i actually went on a trip to spain
in between the first interview and um
the last interview okay so it was quite
a while
um like maybe like a couple months i
would say um
and then with the after the final
interview
um i almost missed it because it was the
day that i came back from traveling
um yeah and then two weeks later i was
just
geez yeah so it's like wait wait wait
and then now you're going
okay yeah that's wild so when you get
there what's it like when you first get
there they give you
all the things to bring and then you
don't know anyone else do you meet all
the other
contestants right away um so you meet
them the first night
so yeah so you're kind of sequestered in
a hotel for a bit
and um you have a lot of time to think
by yourself
meet all the producers so yes you don't
meet any of the girls
until um the actual day okay
i was extremely intimidated um you know
when you see like all these gorgeous
women and they're all i mean
for my season they're all just really
intelligent well spoken
um had their life together looked
beautiful and
so i just remember going in and being
like
i have no idea it's like happening
how am i gonna stand out because
everyone here is like a 10. so
it must be the most overwhelmingly
intimidating experience
i can't even imagine oh yeah and then
you and then you get to know everybody
and you become really close friends
and it was fortunate for our season that
the girls were so close and we were so
supportive of each other
yeah i think that was like one of the
only seasons that i'd seen that the
girls were
like that like that supportive of each
other during
um an instance that is so emotional
there's so much going on
oh it's yeah though i mean you're pitted
against each other in so many ways that
the unlikely story is that you become
friends and that's why it's so sweet to
see that when it happens
the so no you're going in and you know
that they've pegged you as like the
quote weirdo or the
you know person with a couple of
interesting hobbies
did you have a a say in
how your introduction went how you're
like first night
like uh yeah okay yeah i definitely did
i mean i think they help you with ideas
you know that kind of like you and help
you stand out
um for me i just wanted to kind of go
out of the limo and
be just like be normal yeah i didn't
have any sort of gimmick when i first
came out um because i feel like a lot of
the stuff that happened later in the
show would speak for itself um
so it's like i have a lot of weird
things going on and i don't need to like
you know do something crazy in the
beginning
i did write a song for him and i played
that song from the first for the first
episode when i first met him
oh that's great i mean that whole
environment because you don't have your
phone right you have no access to
internet to the outside world at all i
you're really just trusting your
instincts and your intentions constantly
to be like this is who i am i'm
portraying myself as myself
and everything else is out of my hands
the uh
as the season went on what were some of
the most
interesting things for you was it like
the friendships with the girls was it
the the random travel that you guys were
doing or was it just like the pure
like weight of the isolation of it all
i think um something that's really stuck
with me from being on the show is that
you learn so much about
yourself in love so
you have no input from friends or family
um it's pretty much just you figuring
out this relationship
i think that's some so foreign to so
many people especially
for me it was because i was so used to
the input of everyone that was so close
to me in my life
um it was the first time i was really
just left to
make up my own mind um yeah which is so
weird
we're usually like oh here's the guy
that i'm dating and this is what he did
with all of our friends
i think i really grew a lot with that
and i've never thought about that
perspective before that you really don't
have the
the go-to's that you would normally have
in real life to be like what do you
think about this so here's how this date
went
wild how we feel about the person on to
other people and it kind of helps us
figure out how we feel
um based on like their reaction but yeah
no i didn't have that
and i also i feel like with that i made
so many leaps and bounds with
finding what i truly wanted and who i
truly wanted to be in a relationship
um so that's me that i carried with me
um and also every day is unpredictable
you know
tomorrow you can be flying to europe and
you have no idea
um so that was i really enjoyed that
yeah well that's great yeah because i
feel like the people that aren't
so um comfortable with uncertainty
like that will come to the surface
pretty quickly
for yourself and you have to confront
that oh yeah
so you went from bachelor to bachelor in
paradise
uh how what was like was that
immediately after how
what was the timeline on that um so
we had our whole season that aired and
then
the guys filmed with becca her season
um and then the first episode aired and
then we went to paradise
wow okay so you got to watch the airing
of your season
yeah with everyone okay what was that
experience like
watching it back for the first time so
we're watching yourself
first of all hearing your voice is so
annoying like when you first
you're like do i really sound like that
yeah
then you see like little quirks that you
do no one else notices of course but
yeah i was it was so trippy looking back
and seeing my
just watching myself right but it was
cool i mean it was an amazing experience
and i really enjoyed being able to share
something that
was such a crazy experience with people
that were so close to me
yeah and yeah it was just a really fun
it was just kind of fun to to like see
everything
happen you know totally yeah and to make
sure that they didn't
make you the villain at all right i was
like i was in my mind
i was like how how would i ever be
portrayed as a villain you never know
but
right literally it just shows who you
truly are it's hard for them to make you
something that you're not
totally now what was uh
to say yes to bachelor in paradise was
that an easy decision
oh yeah very easy um i loved all the
producers and i loved um
everybody working on the show and people
that i was with on the show
so for me i just saw it as like another
fun adventure
and i'm just really excited about it
cool
did i so you're going into bachelor in
paradise which is different than going
into the bachelor because
you you're meeting people that you know
from tv
at the same time as you're meeting other
people who are in the same
like reality boat as you like what was
how was that for you walking into that
having a little bit of experience of the
bachelor under your belt but still a
big unknown um
it was it was interesting i mean because
you you have so much experience but it's
such a different thing
um it's not a bunch of girls going for
one guy
it's equal guys equal girls we're all
trying to figure out if we um
have a connection with anybody there so
i felt like there was a little bit less
pressure
in that sense um i didn't feel like i
had to make a connection with this one
person or else
i just you know why was i there right um
there's always a chance to make a
connection and i got lucky
in finding connection when i was there
yeah
yeah so i almost felt like so much more
relaxed i didn't feel as uptight
that's very cool and now like so you
make a connection
you have a real life relationship after
the show
that's a very public relationship after
the show
had you ever had anything that intense
before
i mean i can't i try to put myself in
that position that seems so wild to me
like uh just having so many different
eyes
on your relationship yeah as much as it
is just a relationship between you two
it also feels like your family and
friend group has expanded times
a million you know so you have a lot of
different perspectives and people who
are looking out for you or don't think
you're right for each other or
just a lot of opinions um yeah i can't
imagine like
you must have had so many dms and
messages from people just
all over the place with inserting their
opinions on things that were very
private
completely completely i think it almost
worked in the favor of our relationship
because um we were able to establish
trust so much so much quicker and really
helped each other through a lot of the
emotional ups and downs because there's
a lot of
amazing things and then there's a lot of
stressful things that you never
anticipated having to deal with
so in that sense we really became
like so much closer than any of the
relationships i had in the past
i hadn't thought about that before okay
we're going to take a quick break when
we get back
i want to talk a little bit more about
uh the bachelor franchise and
the new book that you have coming out
the new notebook i'm so excited so we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to
hosted by me grace helbig just wanted to
say a couple of things
one thank you so much for listening and
two
if you are enjoying yourself to such a
degree that you'd love to leave
us a review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be uh and that was my
couple of things
now back to me me
you to me in looking at your social
media
you have really mastered uh
influencing in a way that i'm very very
impressed by because i'm so bad at it
but you take it so bad too so it means a
lot
you take great photos i feel like maybe
there's something from your set dressing
past that comes into your ability to
take photos
uh do you have any tips or tricks for
how you handle your social media
um i think what i've learned is that the
more you try to
make posts just for your audience the
more the actual
brand suffers um i think the best thing
was to just really showcase what i truly
like i was afraid for so long to show
the taxidermy side of me
because i felt like yeah i felt like you
know there's a lot of scrutiny behind
that people
um you know obviously there's a lot of
people who care about animals and
i do too which is why i love taxidermy
but um
i think that more so recently i've i've
learned to really celebrate that side of
myself and to want to showcase things
that i
that i love yeah and that's and that's
what all people want all people want to
do is just to kind of see you for who
you genuinely
genuinely are um yeah and also have some
amazing friends who
are very talented with cameras that that
helps
okay so how where did the the love or
interest in taxidermy
start because it is so fascinating yeah
as well
a long time ago i've always been into
animals um
documentaries i've always read about
them and when i was really young i went
to a
local national natural history museum
that was on a hiking trail
and it was the first time that i saw
animals preserved
um and you can see bobcats up close you
can see mountain lions up close
and i thought it was so fascinating to
be able to see that but yeah i went in
there and i saw that
and then i discovered oh i can collect
this stuff myself like i didn't even
know
you can collect preserved animals and
before that i had just
found um skulls or different animals
that would
rot you know like you do
yeah like as one does yeah i always
found it to be extremely beautiful
um and inspiring and um i loved to
be inspired by things around me that i
had read about
so that's kind of how it started and it
it's always been like a side hobby of
mine
it's so when did you do your first
taxidermying well i'm not really i'm not
a taxidermist i actually just collected
oh okay first time i actually made taxes
for me was on the show
oh really yeah during um my hometown
date with ari
i was like i've always wanted to make
taxidermy um
can we do this and they're like yeah
they're like yes great
um and um bishop's taxidermy was where
we had done it and
because i was a creative director that's
where i would get all the taxidermy for
sets and had a good relationship with
them and so
i was able to use that relationship um
for the shoot
and it was it was really fun oh that's
awesome so what's the
i guess what's the biggest misconception
that people would have about the world
of taxidermy
um i think a lot of people see fear
in death they see death as like being
faced with their own mortality
and for me it's more so a way to
appreciate
life and i just see it as the art of
nature preserved
so when i'm around taxidermy i don't
think this thing's dead this thing's
deceased i think
isn't it amazing everything that in the
world and the universe and in life that
has led to this
being this creature being what it is now
so
i see it from very scientific
perspective and it's extremely beautiful
to me
and you can see how things work and um i
think i just would love if people
would see the beauty first as opposed to
something that is no like nothing's
permanent
right in the world so um
i think it's it's really humbling to be
in the presence of that and it's also
really really beautiful and fun yeah
that's a very
very beautiful way to think about that i
feel like that is just a little bit of
shifting your
your mind's focus when you're looking at
something like that because the
immediate reaction is you know fear
terror all of those things so yeah
it's interesting to try and think of it
more in a beautiful sense do you have a
prized piece of taxidermy
um i have my favorites um king which is
my
little duckling with me um during
filming of the bachelor so
he came to paris he came to peru he was
everywhere
well traveled well traveled little
duckling and it's so funny some people
would see it
in the airport they like unzip my bag
you know when they check
and they're like okay
got it we don't i mean i think this is
allowed
it's not technically not allowed so sure
i was like can i bring this out of the
country
and i never you ever got pulled out so
you know i mean it is a
it's a stuffed animal so if they're
letting other stuffed animals on with
children
it's technically that yeah yeah
uh so okay let's talk about just curious
a notebook of questions
this is your book that is coming out
november 18.
yes amazing so how did this come about
um i've been collecting things for as
long as i can remember
um and questions was one of those things
i would always have a notebook with me
in my
backpack and it really just served as a
tool for me to get to know people that
much better
i was really shy when i was a kid um so
it was able i used it to kind of start
conversations with people and to have
fun doing it
um i brought it on first dates i brought
it at parties with friends and
with family events so it was just
something that i had held
near and dear to my heart it was very
personal to me um and i brought it on
the show
as i normally do when i travel or go to
places and um
i brought up one of the episodes with
ari when i was on a date with him
and it just kind of took off people were
really excited about it
and um i asked arya if he would ever eat
human meat
and that was what i'm curious about so
um
because of that there was like a demand
for the book and a curiosity behind it
and i put it off for a while and then
coveted hit and i was like you know what
this is something that i
i love so much in a world where people
are struggling with connection and
trying to fight to um find a connection
in people
like this is just such a perfect a
perfect book for this moment
i mean it's great to be coming from a
franchise that is about finding love and
going through the journey like
the foundation of it is getting to know
each other
and so i think a lot of people don't
know how to do that necessarily and it
might seem like an easy thing of being
like just ask questions but that can be
very difficult for people to figure out
like
what to ask how to ask so so how
this book is a book of questions for
people to use to get to know other
people
how long have you been collecting these
questions since you were a child you
said
um i think it really started in college
when i was thrust into a completely
different
world as one is when they moved to go to
school um
so you kind of you're kind of starting
over so i found myself
wanting to meet new people and really
take advantage of the relationships that
i
had along the way and so it really just
started there
and um i am still collecting them i have
500 plus
and wow the book is just like a small
percentage
um of my most favorite ones that i found
had started the most
really interesting conversations or
really expedited my relationships with
people that much more
um so yeah these are like my my top top
150 questions
do you have go to questions that you
um when you're first getting to know
someone are there like a handful of your
go-to's oh what would those
what would those be um so my favorite
one to ask someone when i first meet
them is
at what age do you did you learn the
most about yourself
um yeah
yeah that's a great question uh what's
your answer for that
for me i mean it changes all the time
but yeah
my favorite answer for that is when i
did go to college when i did
um go to a completely different place i
was um independent for the first time in
a new place for the first time
i was also working through a lot of um
what i thought was right and what i
thought the world should be
was completely shifted and transformed
and um i found myself really being so
much more malleable
in that in that time and still try to
continue to be
and yeah it was just so exciting and um
so yeah that was that that was
definitely the time for me how about you
when was what age do you think we were
in the movie
honestly i think i'm a little bit in it
right now i think this whole last year
this whole pandemic year has really
shifted a lot of focus um for myself and
a lot of people
so but i love that a question like that
really does
change as you grow up so it's like a
question that you can ask
the same person multiple times and
probably get different answers
oh yeah and i have and it's you know and
it's been it was my sister it always
changes as well so
we're twins so even with someone that
you think you know
from the womb like i've known anybody
i'm so close
to her um i still use this book
to um to still check in
check this out yeah speaking of shifting
yeah
how did you decide on the questions that
you put in the book did you
like talk to friends family get kind of
feedback on it or were you just like i'm
putting them all in here
um i so i did get a lot of feedback from
friends and family
and just from using it over years and
years
um the questions that were the most fun
to talk about with friends and the ones
that really
um helped me get to know people at a
more personal level
um yeah and there was like you know
cutting your babies at the end where
there's so many questions that i loved
and that i wanted to put in the book
but you know you have to you have to
choose
like which ones and it was hard for me
yeah because there's so many great ones
it lends itself to another book exactly
it is i can see this is a whole series
so when you come off of a franchise like
this i always find it interesting
because you're probably thrown so many
things to promote or so many things to
you know sponsor etc like the
was the book something that just felt
the most natural the most like
part of you and what you are interested
in
yeah i mean it shapes so much of who i
am so yeah i feel like it was the most
personal thing
that i could share with everybody just
because
um it it was a tool and it still
continues to be
a tool for me um to find out like
to figure out more about who i am and
who other people are around me
um yeah and i i use it all i mean i
bring it on first dates
uh that's been really fun so i i thought
it was like just a really fun thing
to share with people too oh it's great
especially with pandemic with quarantine
and with how people have to like date
now it truly is like this sort of i need
to get to know you
i can't physically hang out with you so
much so this is a great foundational
tool for all of that
um i had a question about do you think
that being on the bachelor of bachelor
in paradise kind of prepared you for the
quarantine because it feels like you
guys are
quarantined in that environment kind of
i mean
there were there's i definitely wasn't
talking to my friends and family when i
was on the show
although i still of course have contact
with them now um
just physically being with somebody
definitely um
i quite liked being cut off from the
world when we were filming i i
i take my phone please i don't have to
worry about this so much
is fun um and with the pandemic i feel
like a lot of people kind of feel that
way with
with work you know um just having almost
like a forced
vacation if you can call a vacation but
a force like inner reflection
you know there's something so
alleviating there's like the stress
kind of dissipates a little bit um and
replaced with other stress but at the
same time
it's nice to be able to take time or be
forced to take time for yourself
totally um also i've read that you
supposedly once drove a car off a ramp
and threw a moving train
oh yeah that was in my uh that was in my
bio
is this true it is true yeah it is true
what is this story um
it's uh i'm trying to see how how much
detail i can go into it's like
i'm not allowed to talk too much about
it yeah but
um but yeah it was kind of just like one
of those crazy experiences that i i was
able to do
and um i have a friend who was
a uh what's it called a um
not special effects but when i do like
all those crazy things that gave me a
lot of advice with it and
oh cool yeah it was just like a really
fun experience and not many people can
say they've done that even like
professional
uh yeah i love that the i mean there's
so much
mystery that shrouds this whole thing
because you can't talk about it i'm like
now all i want to know is about this
i'm running away from the cops and like
you know
come house it was a weird thursday who
knows yeah
yeah right um okay we're going to take
one last break when we get back i have a
bunch of questions from instagram
for you so we'll be right back with more
not too deep
all right kendall before we get into
these instagram questions i'm gonna ask
you the two questions i ask every single
guest that is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most
want to throw cold spaghetti at oh cold
spaghetti
like as a joke you get to decide the
intention in which you throw it
i'm trying to think
maybe my sister ah yeah
that would get it and she'd laugh um
she probably pissed a little bit it's so
funny like picturing doing it to a
stranger
without any context and these
times i feel like uh a situation like
that could go
real bad real quick um so you have some
sense of humor so maybe i'd
choose like a comedian maybe jim carrey
i think
that would be great i would love to see
that
uh okay the other question we ask every
guest is to tell us your worst pant
[ __ ] story
or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
for example
mine is college jogging front lawn
yeah man i'm trying to think mine would
be
and it can be just a close call
situation
yeah let's call situation i'm just
trying to think
like i'm sure there's been so many of
them i know these are the things that
you either have one immediately or
you've repressed it so deeply that it's
hard to recall
i must um i'm almost thinking like
um first grade
cartwheel yeah yeah that's a gravity is
not in your favor there
okay let's get into some instagram
questions um
before we do what what would you say is
your favorite
platform for social media do you have
one would it be instagram
instagram yeah um it's been i think it's
been a platform that i'm
the most comfortable using and uh i can
showcase a lot of my personality on
there and i've
met a lot of people through there and
have had some great experiences
so definitely cool uh okay well then
these questions will be right at home
uh someone wants to know what is the
worst worst worst
part about being on the show i assume
it's being in a bra all day
oh i don't i didn't wear bras i don't
really wear bra
but yes i would i would say the worst
worst
worst part would be um
obviously bullying that's something like
you know after the show it's one of
those things you can't really control so
you have to learn to let it go but
not fun and i think a lot of people that
have been like on tv in general
experience
that yeah so that's no problem yeah it
must be wild
because the and we've talked to a couple
guests before about just the
frenzy of the bachelor nation is that
you've become part of this like very
sacred community
almost and it must be
yeah so do you guys all do you all still
keep in touch like here and there with
the people that you've met through the
show
we we definitely do i would say because
of the pandemic
um we have i haven't been able to
physically be with anybody um
but i was really fortunate to have so
many amazing relationships there's a lot
of really
great girls in my season so i definitely
still talk to people from there
um and on paradise you know it's you go
through such a crazy
experience that you have something in
common with these people that
you you know no one else can relate to
so um yeah it's just
cool to still share that would you do
another season
so in order to be on the bachelor uh you
have to be single so it's one of those
things
um i'm still i'm dating and i and i want
to find somebody so i'm definitely not
holding myself off um from finding love
but i mean i love being on the show it
was so great it's there's only positive
that came from it and
it's just um it is one of the most
honest
like forms of like tv like i didn't know
it existed so
um people can like it could be such a
real experience and
um i actually loved being a part of it
so yeah i mean
i would not i wouldn't say no would you
do any other reality
shows is there any others that you'd be
dying to get on
it just depends what it is i was like i
was thinking of an amazing race to be
super fun
oh you and your sister doing amazing
race
so fun oh great british baking show
british to do that but i would love to
i mean i'm not a good baker i'm just not
but i would love to
do that i mean paul improved oh gosh
i know i would never get a handshake
from paul but that would be okay
right okay someone wants to know
uh what is the strangest animal that
you've seen stuffed
and is stuck the right word for a
taxidermy so there's so many different
ways
you can preserve like a living thing um
stuffed is definitely one of them
um the most interesting mounts i've seen
were in taxidermy um competitions where
they can
create their own mounts from pieces of
animals that don't
um that that if the the finished product
isn't if that makes sense so wow
um there was a guy who made like a panda
bear
out of different like skins and
different things um because it's illegal
to stuff a panda bear because they are
endangered
so um i love the creativity with that
you know yeah
so lifelike and real um based off of
something that it isn't
you know wow i didn't yeah that's very
innovative
very cool uh someone wants to know
is the bachelorette as dramatic in real
life as it is on tv
um yeah i mean yes
it's like everything that you see is
genuinely what happens
um of course there might not be dramatic
music um
right yeah you don't get to hear all the
sound cues yeah that enlightens
everything but
all the feelings that you see and all
the reactions are extremely real and
genuine and
um every tear that i cried was a guy
legit was crying i don't know how to
fake
cries so um yeah it's a
it there's a lot that you go through
emotionally but it's all
definitely worth it regardless of
whether it goes like a good or a bad
experience you know yeah
you did it i mean it also seems like
it's just exhausting
like you are yeah up all hours and
you're on camera
having to be yourself all the time and
remind yourself who you are
it's unpredictable you know you just
don't know what's going to happen the
next day
and i loved that like that was an
element that i loved about the show
and not a lot of people liked it i mean
some people you know really to like not
have enough control over their lives but
for me i was like i surrender to
whatever this is
let's let's figure it out yeah that
feels like the best piece of advice for
anyone going on in the future
uh oh i wanted to ask what was your um
meeting chris harrison for the first
time like it was
he's so different than i expected really
so
like proper together and he is he's very
well spoken
but he's hilarious like he's funny he's
dirty jokes like he's just like
yeah this is like an example of someone
who's so comfortable with who they are
after doing this over and over again um
yeah he's a he's he's a cool guy and
that must be
very reassuring to be in that kind of
crazy environment
and then just to have someone that is
reliable and comfortable
there kind of leading the way that must
have been really nice
yeah you know i'm pretty sure at this
point there's probably nothing that he
hasn't seen
so yeah you don't feel like you're so
alone
in an experience when there's people
around you who have
been through it um yeah it's nice to
have that
camaraderie camaraderie right yeah
someone's asking bachelorette
predictions have you been watching the
newest season
oh i have okay what are your thoughts i
was just trying to finish watching the
most recent i guess episode two
it was um because i haven't i didn't
catch episode one but what are your
thoughts on this season
i mean it it's definitely so early and
there's a lot of waters coming out there
so um i feel like
obviously claire is very into jail
it's not a surprise yeah i my hope and
with a lot of bachelorettes in the past
um they have been so into one person
and then they switched at the end so i
think it'd be interesting
if um she thought it was jail the entire
time
and then maybe something happens that
changes that yeah
my hope is that she leaves room in
curiosity for other
relationships just because i think
people can surprise you
oh totally yeah that you don't get
blinded by a first impression
yeah yeah do you watch you must watch
the show now with totally different eyes
and be able to see like uh and watching
from the outside i'm sure
is so much easier than being on the
inside yeah well you can see people
thinking you know what was i thinking
during this time how was
i in the beginning of the show you you
can tell people are just like what is
happening
and how am i you know you're you're like
you're like i hope i don't pick
everything in my teeth i hope you know
something
people like thinking as they're talking
you know in the beginning it seemed
so awkward in the beginning oh yeah
everyone i feel like is trying to get a
handle
on the control like controlling what
their narrative how
they are and that can be so overwhelming
um
someone wants to know what's your
favorite kind of cheese oh my gosh
i love cheese so much oh gosh yeah i
mean it's just gray oh i love
i love brie so there's this um
little corner store in west hollywood
that's like right next to this
italian place called cherone that has
like this awesome little brie
and it's so good oh that sounds amazing
um someone asked who from ari season
is she still super close with um
i would say i talked to a few of the
girls um
becca martinez she just had her second
baby i love her
um we haven't caught up in a while just
because of covid and you know
children during home it's difficult um
i still talk to jacqueline she is in new
york
she has a podcast now um
becca who was a bachelorette just moved
to los angeles so i recently saw her
um no i still keep in touch and it's
it's great to be able to
um like you know still be able to catch
up even in a time that's so difficult
right now to
you know have connections um okay
last question what is something you wish
viewers would know about the show but
was always edited out
or maybe what's just something you wish
viewers knew more about the show
um you're trying to think i mean i i
just wish people
knew that it was completely real
you know because i think i think that
and also that um we're
all just normal people who make mistakes
and are still trying to figure out what
love is i think
people look at it and they think because
you're on a show you have to be like
this perfect archaea type of
you know love and finding love and if
you make any mistakes then
you're open to be scrutinized where it's
like we're all human we're all in this
together we're all
we all want to be loved um and
i think like if people can can see that
or they can
try to relate more to the people that
are on there and have more empathy
yeah yeah that i mean that must be so
interesting because
it has become such a well-known
franchise that
it's almost like this weird entitled
ownership of the people that are on the
show
by the audience and it's like hunger
games almost
of like choose your fighter and then uh
you forget to see them as complex human
beings at the end of the day
yeah and i'm like you know everyone's so
different everyone's had so many
different experiences that leads them to
making the
decisions that they do and you know it's
yeah and i love seeing how each and
every individual person handles the same
experience
yeah different factors but um but yeah
it's a it's a wild ride
and uh yeah i think i think
i i don't know it's just hard to explain
it's like one of those things
oh it's i mean and that's why it makes
sense that you guys all end up being
close to each other after the show
because it's such a unique experience
that when you're able to talk to someone
else that's had that
first-hand experience i'm sure it's like
oh we can speak the same language to
each other now
no happy turns back yeah that's very
sweet
yeah uh kendall this has been so fun
before we wrap up completely usually
when we do this in person back in you
know the before times
uh we would give a personalized fortune
cookie to thank you for being on the
show
but we have a virtual fortune cookie for
you today
if i believe melissa has emailed it to
you yes
oh my goodness it's so funny
uh chicago deep dish sucks anyway
it does yeah i've had it before
it's fine i like crust pizza
yeah now kendall where can people find
you where can they get the book where
can they see what you're up to if they
don't already know
so my instagram is it's kendall long and
i put everything on there uh
basically just like a little you know
narration of my life
um and for the book um kendallong.com
so right now i have specialty editions
available but the book launches november
18th so that's where
it like the book yeah oh i'm so excited
congratulations on everything guys go
get this book it's not only great for
dating
it's great for getting to know your
friends your family the strangers in
your life that you might not know that
you have a connection with um
thank you again so much kendall this was
so fun thank you so much grace yeah it
was fun had fun
uh we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep
goodbye too deep too deep
too deep not too deep with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music